a Ford Focus RS here painted nitrous
blue claims the crown among the hot
hatches vehicles for both everyday use
and sport driving it has huge air
intakes 235 Michelin Super Sport tires
and a Brembo brake on the front axle a
large rear wing and a diffuser with two
large tailpipes
endless our car tester undulate
zimmerman has been looking forward
eagerly to the Ford Focus RS Ford's
engineers have given it not only lots of
power but also intelligent all-wheel
drive beside the gearshift knob are the
buttons to shift among drive modes with
a choice of normal sport and two other
modes designed for restricted roadways
namely racetrack mode and drift mode the
ladder is a novelty in this segment and
unique among compact sports cars
Andre can't wait to let the car rip but
first he has to reach the track so he's
going to start with normal
the Focus RS has 257 kilowatts of power
underscoring its claim to the throne of
the hatchback rim with a top speed of
260 six kilometers an hour it will leave
most cars on the highway in the dust the
power comes from a 2.3 litre EcoBoost
engine a similar engine is in Fords
current Mustang but the EcoBoost was
thoroughly revised for the Rs
as a d-link Oh her car tester is
impressed with a very direct steering he
likes the stiffness and resistance which
isn't so extreme that steering requires
strong muscles the car moves forward
well but Andre says he can't resist the
temptation to leave normal mode for
sport mode my time off sport sport mode
provides aggressive throttle response
even stiffer steering and a more
aggressive sound
in sport mode the all-wheel drive also
provides more power for longer periods
to the outside rear wheel and curves and
the result is impressive
andele can hardly contain his enthusiasm
for the all-wheel-drive just when you
think you can't take the curve any
faster the outside rear wheel pushes
even more and when the weather leaves
the road wet like today you really
notice how the rear adds power the car
doesn't understeer to provoke
understeering you really have to whip
the steering wheel around Honda is
thrilled at how the Ford Focus RS
handles as though handling message
absolutes for their Ford Focus s we've
arrived at the Valencia racetrack Andre
explains that we'll be using a different
car not because it's painted like a
racing car but because it has Michelin
Pilot Sport cup two tires
Michelin and Ford collaborated to tailor
the semi slick tire specifically for the
Focus RS to provide maximum grip on the
racetrack Andre wants to see if that's
true and what driving and racetrack mode
is like the racetrack mode automatically
adjusts the suspension to be 40% stiffer
even hobby drivers get good lap times
with it the electronic stability program
shifts to a special sport mode but it
can be manually shut off
Andre says track mode is initially less
playful than sport mode you have to know
what you're doing but the car provides
lots of feedback and the mechanical grip
is very good so all your options are
open if you let up on the gas pedal the
rear turns a bit so to a degree you can
steer with the accelerator on today
can't get over the grip which allows him
to really play with the car he warns
that a driver should feel his way into
controlling the vehicle but the chassis
is really very very competent hands as
their competences
Reis track mode is for fast lap times if
you want to accelerate from zero to 100
faster than a Porsche 718 boxer use the
launch control side we're gonna put it
in drift mode yes so what we're gonna do
is we do this all in first gear yes
we're gonna drive into the circle okay
we're gonna start to turn yes and once
we're gonna be about 2 meters from the
cones yes only doing about 25 kilometers
now are quite slow I'm gonna start the
turn and maybe when we're about by the
Mitchell ensign I'm gonna shout gasps
okay when I shout gasps give it full gas
all the way to the floor
yes back-end or come round catch it and
then just literally playing with the
steering turning tighter looser
maybe feather the throttle but you don't
have to see how we go yeah okay
yeah this is amazing
- fragmented focus Andre is sad that his
test-drive with a focus RS is over he
says Ford has done a fantastic job of
bridging the gap between a car for
ordinary driving on ordinary streets and
one you can perfectly control in extreme
situations the competition has nothing
like it and the Focus RS comes with a
price tag of just 40000 euros well
that's to acquire the vehicle operating
costs are another matter because for
drift mode first you need a restricted
racetrack plus there's greatly increased
wears on the tyres and your fuel
consumption will exceed the new European
driving cycle emission guidelines but
hey think of all the fun you'll have